it started off as a knock at Carissa
Nash's front door in Forney I look at my
doorbell camera on my phone first before
going to the door and I see it's a
little kid that little kid is her
nine-year-old neighbor with the whip in
hand the Kaufman County Precinct 2
Constable says the boy may have been
trying to confront the Nash family's
nine-year-old daughter then after the
second whip
from off my porch beating on my door
like these I will call the police you
need to leave it happened on Thursday
afternoon off of cross-cut Drive in
Forney when Dad
desira Nash got home coming to have a
conversation with you sir your son I'll
show you the video okay so he beat on
your door okay
can you come look at our car seconds
later can you please stop sir
authorities say neighbor Ryan Brunson
had a gun in his right hand
officers say the gun went off firing in
the direction of Brian's daughter
standing directly behind him oh my God
God Precinct 2 officers arrested Brunson
and charged him with deadly conduct we
tried to get Brian brunson's side of the
story I spoke to him on the phone
briefly where he posted Bond and tells
me there is a lot more to the story and
that he now has an attorney authorities
tell us all of this may have stemmed
from when the kids were walking home
from school this stems from a bullying
issue uh between
the victim's daughter and the young boy
with the will there's been several
interactions between two of them at
different times in different locations
and in an escalated because the dad
threw like he pull out a gun
and was like blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah sat the gun down on the porch
started talking then escalated he
grabbed the gun again didn't handle the
gun properly discharged the gun now that
that is in the classic isn't going
inside take a couple things to
appreciate I did thought it was kind of
funny that when the mom opened the door
she said get off my porch she kind of
stood there like he was gonna whoop her
ass too and then you get back to the
crib the parents confront the father gun
goes off all this stuff and then you
realize like oh that's why the kids that
way
okay
you know just you're not just born this
way you know what I'm saying like most
of child's behavior is socialized a lot
of it a lot of it yeah so when a kid
comes to your door with a whip that
didn't come out of nowhere and where do
you get the Whip and what's the whip
there for
check the little kids Behind pause I'm
sure there's some wit marks
what
I'm not taking no kids Behind
police obviously that's why I said pause
it's not even good why is your kid
having a whip and just playing like that
with a wig that's yo that's just crazy
there's nothing that that there's
what do you want me to add to this so we
don't know why they was looking for
daughter so he almost shot his own
daughter what the bullet almost struck
brunson's own daughter who was standing
behind him I thought I struck the almost
struck the boy it almost struck his to
his young daughter his daughter the
dad's daughter yeah imagine that so you
see with a felony charge yeah cause you
cannot discharge a gun like that for no
reason even if you're like oh yeah oops
sorry oops sorry doesn't doesn't cut it
if you can't oops sorry like a gun
discharge like that and I just I just
appreciate the fact that if you have a
gun if you own a gun and you don't know
how to operate it
you're going to be held accountable for
that so I I appreciate that so this kid
gets into fight with a lot of kids
around the neighborhood apparently
according to what the kid says the 13
year old son had hit him when he was on
his way back from school and so that's
why he was there at the door he wanted
Revenge the parents say it's not
possible because our kid go in school
later because he's 13. so he was not
even around when you were there he's
still at school so how are you saying he
beat you up
to know what the hell really happened I
will wait you know another thing is like
gun rights are fantastic but they also
come with a tremendous amount of
responsibility okay for you to just be
waving your gun around almost shoot like
absolutely irresponsible yeah and you
should go to jail it's not just oh I
want to own guns it's fantastic he's
like they come with responsibilities
yeah and like in terms of parenting like
almost shooting your own daughter
teaching that to your kids potentially
going to jail and being absent from
their life it's like as a parent at what
point do you take accountability that's
crazy this kid really walked out with a
whip and started hitting someone's door
insane yes the entitlement I'm a knock
on your door and I'm gonna end on my you
a kid kid I'm not from Texas all right
so I ain't never been to them Parts one
of the reasons that people own whips
down there what is there like some kind
of like reason that people just own
casually whips
the problem is the problem is you use it
in that setting like it could be for a
bunch of things whips has been part of
the answer of of of of Texas for
numerous reasons but only also because
of cattles because of farming because of
that so let's not think like necessarily
inherently you know and you know
all of that [ __ ] but I'm not saying that
I'm just saying I'm just you not maybe
not but we're talking to people right
there so I'm just going to put that out
there that that's not what we thinking
necessarily so there might be a bunch of
reason it might be for this that and
whatever so it doesn't really matter
what you what you what you own it's how
you use it you're going to take that
Whip and then you're going to go walk
down the street and whip some what the
the reason why I'm bringing up why would
anybody own that is their child when he
felt threatened the first thing he went
to was the whip
then go to a knife no then go to the
other weapon went to the whip which
means he's learned that that is a weapon
this means using it on black folks all
that I'm saying keep Rob using it on his
kids
cause for a child to jump to that
conclusion after seeing the whip listen
if I gotta be for someone I'm grabbing a
stick I'm grabbing things I've seen my
mom use before or I'm grabbing a knife
things I've seen in TV not grabbing a
whip but a whip
if we're talking about distance a whip
is a good
we agree but you have to know that yeah
you have to have seen that yeah you know
what I'm saying maybe he saw Roots a
couple of times as a nine-year-old hey
of course these are assumptions but I do
think it's very telling that a child
will pick that weapon of all that's all
I'm trying to say that's all I'm trying
to say listen if
somebody with a spatula [ __ ] they
didn't just grab that out of nowhere
they let it go into the cash Academy and
look for it why because your mama used
it or you learned that beavers
tomorrow's Awards told you about that
Whip or something like that I'm sorry
but nine-year-olds don't just be
grabbing whips out of nowhere that's
crazy to me
so unless a dad works in farming and I'm
unaware
I don't know that looks a little bit
Shady that's all I'm trying to say I'm
just trying to figure out what kind of
farming you use a whip
I said farming and stuff like that
cattle and stuff like that hmm that's
what I'm saying I don't know but I don't
know there's probably used for that
underwear so you know what let us know
in the comments below some reasons why
people have my own whips I'm unaware
okay uh but yeah me watching this video
I just it's just such an odd video yep
it is yeah it is there's a lot there's a
lot to unfold yeah there's a lot there
yeah just walk first he walks up there
bands away bands on the door who does
that yeah then the whip
I mean yeah you know you got violent
tendencies you get bullied you respond
with violence that's
I'm gonna be honest as a kid I was
pretty violent myself like that's not
too abnormal to me I mean it's the
choice of the weapon and the way he went
about it and then what's unfolded
afterwards that was telling
what because here's the thing most of us
as kids responded with violence to
violence that was normal why because we
learned it from our parents too our
parents beat us so we beat other people
we're not talking so I'm not I'm angry
at the time I'm gonna do that so I'm not
surprised by that me I just think it's
crazy I seen a [ __ ] with a whip
at nine an adult I could have lived with
I've seen adults machetes and samurai
swords okay you can explain that a child
with a samurai sword imma think that's
kind of crazy but a whip Takes the Cake
because that isn't like a different kind
of weapon you need to know what it's for
before you even touch it yeah that's not
something that we just don't like this
[ __ ] is not watching Indiana Jones
every day
so oh this is my thoughts maybe I'm
wrong let us know what you guys think in
the comments but I think it's gonna be
maybe there's gonna be a part two of the
video maybe maybe not because we don't
know if if the information is dull
whatever if it's not I just want to know
what the media is not going to come
apart to this you don't know why because
they already got the back the white boy
with the whip
they got the white boy with the whip at
the door of the black people yes so even
if they're in Texas even if there's a
subsequent story that comes out that
turns out the 13th boy was bullying the
kid or whatever going after you think
they're gonna punish it nobody cares no
nobody cares and there was a gun
discharge no no I'm not gonna break
they're not cover that